In January 2021, a mob occupied the US Capitol, seeking
to overturn the results of the presidential election.
This was a call to duty for America's educators.
While the Capitol attack was
precipitated by former president Trump's
caustic lies, the poisonous polarization it reflected
can be traced to weakness in the nation's civic foundation.
Just a fraction of Americans can name
the three branches of government
or pass the nation's citizenship test.
Most republicans thought Trump's 2016
presidential election victory was fair,
but that his 2020 defeat wasn't.
More than 90 percent of democrats
said Joe Biden's 2020 election was fair,
but nearly half said
Hillary Clinton's 2016 defeat wasn't.
Democracy doesn't work if voters only trust
elections when their side carries the day.
This is a test of our civic mettle.
Our schools and colleges have a crucial
role to play in helping us pass that test.
Do you think it's a problem that most
Americans can't pass the nation's citizenship test?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.